بدايه الثوره حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ابقى
معنا زين في هذا الاطار اعلنت ميليشيا
باجنر الروسيه تعزيز مواقعها في المناطق
الشرقيه بمدينه
واقرت انها خاضت معارك طريه مع القوات
الاوكرانيه في هذه المناطق من جانبه قلل
المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في الشرق
السرهي شيفاتي ان القوات الروسيه تواصل
محاوله شني هجمات
الجديد نتابعه الان من ستلافسيان مع مراسل
الجزيره حسان مسعود وسيكون معنا ايضا
الجزيره امين درغامي وبدايه التطورات
الميدانيه مع حسن مسعود اليك التفاصيل
نعم ازدهار في الوقت الذي ما زالت فيه
المعارك تدور في مدينه باخموت ومحيطها
يبدو ان القوات الروسيه تستهدف المناطق
التي تقع غربيه منطقه بخموت وتحديدا منطقه
قسطنطنيه
هنا نشاهد خلفي مباشره هذا الدخان
المتصاعد من منطقه سلافيانسك هذه احدى
الضربات الصاروخيه التي
اصابت واحده من المناطق
القريبه من المنطقه الصناعيه في منطقه
تشتعل الحرائق هناك ونشاهد اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد من المكان وهذا المشهد رايناه ايضا
قبل قليل في مشهد مشابه في منطقه
كوستانتينيفكا هذه المنطقه الواقعه جنوب
غربي
منطقه بخموت وهناك ايضا كانت تشتعل
الحرائق ويتصاعد الدخان حتى هذه اللحظه
المعلومات الاوليه تشير الى اصابه سته
اشخاص في القصف الذي تعرضت له منطقه
كوستانتينيفكا هذه المنطقه منطقه
قسطنطيفكا هي احدى ابرز المدن التي تحتوي
على طريق اساسي يصل منطقه دوناتسك ومنطقه
باخموت هذه الطريق الاساسيه كانت تحاول
القوات الروسيه ان تقصفها بشكل متواصل
واليوم كان هناك اصابه في داخل بلده
كوستانتينيكا وبعد ذلك نشاهد هذه هذا
الاستهداف الجديد هنا في منطقه حيث ما
زالت النيران تتصاعد وتشتعل واعمده الدخان
تتصاعد منذ حوالي الساعه ونصف في هذا
المكان وحتى هذه اللحظه المعلومات المتاحه
والتي افادنا بها مصدر عسكري للجزيره ان
المنطقه
المستهدفه هي منشاه حيويه لا توجد معلومات
حول المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه المنشاه
ولكن ما نستطيع ان نؤكده ان هناك اصوات
انفجارات ايضا تتصاعد بين الحين والاخر من
اماكن الانفجارات هذا الاستهداف ياتي في
ظل الحديث عن ان المعارك في منطقه باخ
متمازالت متواصله تحدث اليوم المتحدث باسم
قياده عمليات الشرق ان المعركه في باخ
مدخله ليوم الماضي كانت على اشدها وان 41
هجوما تصدت له القوات الاوكرانيه كان من
جانب القوات الروسيه من عدد من الاتجاهات
وهذا يشير الى تصاعد حده المعارك في محيط
منطقه باخموت تحدث عن صد هجوم ايضا عند
الجانب الغربي الجنوبي الغربي لمنطقه
باكموت وهذا ايضا يشير الى مكانه تقوله
الاداره العسكريه وكذلك القوات الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه تحاول ان تطوق المدينه
لكن القوات الاوكرانيه تتصدى لها وفق
قولها نعم قمعنا حسان دعنا نتعرف على
الروايه الروسيه
[تصفيق]
نعم ازدهار مؤسس شركه فاغنر يفغيني قبل
قليل فقط اكد على ان قوات تواصل تقدمها في
ضخمه رغم ما سماه المقاومه الكبيره من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه المدينه وذلك في
رد على سؤال كان بخصوص عمليه
يعني تجنيد مزيد من القوات في صفوف فاجنر
وكشف من خلال جوابه
فتحت 42 مركزا في عموم روسيا من اجل
استقطاب مزيد من المقاتلين الى صفوفها لما
قال انها مسؤوليه ملقاه على عاتق هذه
الشركه العسكريه الروسيه فيما يبدو انه
لربما معارك اخرى تستعد هذه القوات للدخول
فيها بعد الانتهاء من عملياتها في بخموت
على الارض هناك قاده عسكريون في فاجنر
اكادو على انهم سيطروا بالكامل على
المنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه باخمو تحديدا حي
زباخ موتكا وكانت وكاله روسيه قد اظهرت
فيديو
لخسائر القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه المنطقه
عباره عن دبابات واليات عسكريه مدمره
وكانت هناك اتهامات من قبل قوات للجيش
الاوكراني بانه استخدم المباني السكنيه
والاحياء المدنيه في اقامه خطوط دفاع من
اجل منع تقدم قوات فاجنر على ذلك هناك
مواقع مؤيده لروسيا في دومباس تحدثت عن
انفجار الذي تحدث عنه الزميل حسان قبل
قليل في سلافيان على انه استهداف روسي
صاروخي
لمستودع للذخيره تابع للجيش الاوكراني دون
ذكر المزيد من التفاصيل بالاضافه الى
استهدافات اخرى سواء عن طريق رجمات
الصواريخ اول مدفعيه الروسيه لمواقع الجيش
الاوكر في كل من
غربي مدينه
باخموت وايضا في التي تحدثت فاجنر قبل
ايام على ان الجيش الاوكراني يقوم بالدفع
بمزيد من التعزيزات العسكريه الى هاتين
البلدتين في محاوله
اولا الابقاء على طريق الامداد الاخير
مفتوح باتجاه مدينه بخموت ثم منع قوات من
التقدم ومحاصره المدينه والتوجه نحو كل من
موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي ومن
سلافيانسك مراسل الجزيره حسن مسعود شكرا
جزيلا لكما